the 2020 democratic national convention
begins tonight joe biden and his running
mate kamala harris will accept the
party's nomination
in wilmington delaware but the speeches
will mostly be
virtual our latest cbs news battleground
tracker poll finds biden with a 10 point
national lead over president trump 52 to
42 percent
and 66 percent of democrats we talked to
say they're glad biden chose harris to
run with him
ed o'keefe will cover the convention for
us ed what do voters want to hear
from the democratic ticket well anthony
good morning democrats especially tuning
in want to actually see this remain
positive and informational they want to
hear from joe biden and kamala harris
what they would do if they take back the
white house not necessarily those
well-worn attacks on president trump
and vice president pence and after an
historically
large and diverse and competitive
primary season democrats know this week
they've got to demonstrate they are
united
in their race to take back the white
house welcome to the control room
democrats are putting the final touches
on plans for their convention but things
will look
far different this year for the mostly
virtual event
instead of speeches from a sports arena
party leaders are expected to speak for
two hours each night
from across all 57 states and
territories
tonight's focus is expected to be on the
pandemic the struggling economy
and the national reckoning on race and
policing
speakers are set to include former ohio
republican governor john kasich
who's part of biden's bid to win over
gop voters not willing to vote for the
president
senator bernie sanders and former first
lady michelle obama will cap off the
first night
sanders says the party is united in its
goal we have got to do
everything we can to come together to
defeat donald trump
more than 400 people are bringing the
event together from operation centers in
milwaukee
new york los angeles and wilmington
delaware
joe biden's hometown ready he and
running mate kamala harris will speak
from
later this week over the weekend
president trump once again
didn't dismiss false and racist claims
that harris is ineligible to run for
vice president it's not
something that i'm going to be pursuing
is she eligible sir
i just told you i have not gone into it
in great detail
if she's got a problem you would have
thought that she would have been vetted
on sunday aides sought to move past the
president's doubts
do you accept the fact and it is a fact
that senator kamala harris is eligible
to be vice president
sure and i think the president spoke to
this yesterday this is not something
that we're going to pursue
harris anticipates the attacks
doesn't give his big acceptance speech
until thursday night but he is set to
appear tonight in a video conversation
with racial justice leaders and one
other thing democrats need to be wary of
this week
boosting enthusiasm our new poll found
that republicans
are more enthusiastic than democrats to
vote this november
so that's something the party hopes they
can work on over the course of the next
four days
gail that's interesting thank you very
much at o'keefe